et on va parler bien sûr encore de cette
rentrée des classes de la Baya une jeune
adolescente de 14 ans c'est refuser
l'entrée en classe car elle portait un
kimono étant en 4e comme je vous l'ai
dit comprenez vous ces exclusions
comment définir ce qu'est une abaya ce
qui n'est pas alors je vais vous dire ça
déjà ça va être un bordel on va vous
dire il faut maintenant il faut des
stylistes à l'entrée des établissements
non mais c'est engrais comment comment
on sait je vous dis ça ça va être un
bordel pas possible et je crois que ça
peu de gens l'avaient anticipé regardez
petit récap ils sont papa sera avec nous
également dans un instant qui va nous
dire ce qui s'est passé vous allez voir
la la photo de comment elle est habillée
et son papa veut la défendre ce soir
dans TPMP c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est le sujet brûlant de cette rentrée
la Bayard qui est un vêtement religieux
et donc prohiber je ne savais pas que la
Bayette un signe religieux depuis que
Gabriel Attal a annoncé l'interdiction à
l'école de cette robe longue qui couvre
le corps certaines adolescentes
dénoncent des dérives dans cette
restriction a été exclue de son lycée
car elle portait un kimono une exclusion
suivie par d'autres dont celle de cet
élève de 4e renvoyé pour avoir à son
tour porté ce kimono rose un vêtement
ample d'origine japonaise le père de la
collegienne qui crée aujourd'hui à la
discrimination s'exprime ce soir dans
TPMP alors comprenez vous la décision du
chef d'établissement
et oui j'ai la ni merci d'être avec nous
merci votre fille n'a pas pu entrer en
classe cette semaine parce qu'elle
portait cette tenue j'aimerais que dans
le débat on reste sur cette tenue voilà
qu'on commence pas à chercher le sujet
en général parce qu'on en a déjà parlé
cette tenue a été refusée ce que vous
comprenez est-ce que vous comprenez la
décision de l'établissement on peut
mettre la question s'il vous plaît Karim
Zeribi et Eric Naulleau sont avec nous
pour cette cette BRI une adolescente de
4e renvoyée de son collège car elle
portait un kimono la question s'il vous
plaît c'est important pour les
téléspectateurs comprenez-vous la
décision de l'établissement
Eric Naulleau vous la comprenez je la
comprends parfaitement parce que cette
tenue là parce qu'il y a des problèmes
très graves en ce moment à l'éducation
nationale il y a la lutte contre
l'islamisme vous avez vu que le Conseil
d'État a validé l'interdiction de la
Baya il y a le problème du harcèlement
vous avez vu qu'un gamin de 15 ans s'est
pendu et il y a un troisième problème
c'est l'effondrement du niveau scolaire
que ça soit celui des élèves ou des
professeurs et selon moi il y a des
problèmes dérisoires et parmi les
problèmes dérisoirs je classe les états
d'âme d'une collégienne par rapport à sa
tenue si l'établissement décide que sa
tenue n'est pas adéquate la décision
s'impose votre fille mais je dis votre
fille parce qu'on parle d'elle mais ça
vaut pas évidemment pour tout le monde
je ne personnalise pas le débat peut
porter ce kimono chez elle peut porter
ce qui mono dans la rue peut le porter
où elle veut sauf à l'école ou c'est le
chef d'établissement qui va décider donc
écoutez maintenant il faut arrêter
d'encombrer l'actualité avec des faux
problèmes des faux sujets et se
concentrer sur ce que j'ai dit la lutte
contre l'islamisme la lutte contre le
harcèlement et le relèvement du niveau
scolaire tout le reste c'est dérisoire
c'est anodin ça ne fait qu'encombrer
l'actualité et nous empêcher de
réfléchir voilà pourquoi je suis
favorable il va vous répondre dans le
soutien la décision de l'établissement
et Annie va vous répondre dans un
instant Karim c'est rébi je trouve qu'il
rigolo a dit une seule chose
d'intéressante dans son propos c'est
qu'il fallait c'est qu'il fallait
s'attacher
que j'ai prioritaire et c'est le seul
point sur lequel nous serons d'accord et
en l'occurrence une jeune fille qui
arrive avec une tunique de pièces
comme on peut en trouver donc de partout
je ne vois pas en quoi cela contrevient
au principe de laïcité et je le précise
auquel je tiens car je trouve important
que les principes de laïcité sont
respectés que les signaux religieux
soient restent à l'extérieur qui pas
croient voile que je suis une défenseur
de l'école publique et laïque mais là je
trouve Converse dans le délire on verse
dans le délire parce que je ne vois pas
en quoi cette tenue a une quelconque
référence avec le religieux et donc je
trouve que nous vous une boîte de
Pandore qui devient dangereuse avec une
forme de stigmatisation discrimination à
quoi va-t-on décider qu'une tenue est
acceptable ou pas est-ce que c'est au
faciès de jeunes filles est-ce que si
une blonde donc facial européen porte
cette tenue est-ce qu'on va lui dire
qu'elle n'est pas acceptable j'en doute
fort moi je vous le dis sur ça
la couleur et tout je vois pas le je
comprends pas en fait exact et je vous
le dis je suis d'autant plus choqué que
avant-hier on a eu une nouvelle encore
catastrophique dans le pays un jeune de
15 ans c'est pendu à Poissy en raison du
harcèlement scolaire il y a 850000
gamins qui sont victimes de harcèlement
scolaire dans notre pays il y a eu 68
cas d'abaya à la rentrée scolaire on
nous a fait du à Baya matin midi et soir
une semaine avant la rentrée scolaire et
ben il y a pas eu de problème donc
curieusement parce que les filles ne
sont pas là pour créer de soucis elles
veulent étudier trouver leur place à la
société ne sont pas le bras des
islamistes vous parlez d'une offensive
islamiste avec 28 filles sur 12 millions
d'étudiants non mais il faut qu'on
arrête le délire il faut qu'on revienne
à l'essentiel il y a des gamins en 6e
qui savent pas lire il y a 850 000
gamins qui sont victimes de harcèlement
il y a 160000 gamins qui sont victimes
d'inceste et vous allez me parler d'une
tenue de pièce qu'on trouverait dans
tous les magasins et que tous tes jeunes
filles peuvent porter on est dans le
délire il faut que ce délire s'arrête il
faut qu'on revienne à l'essentiel aux
priorités le priorité c'est que ces
filles puissent étudier tranquillement
comme les autres sans être coincé du
doigt et qu'on abandonne un petit peu
cette forme d'hystérie autour de l'islam
et des musulmans laissez-les tranquille
les musulmans qui sont pas d'accord avec
nous on va les avoir dans un instant
bien sûr
j'ai eu l'impression qu'en Cyril vous a
demandé est-ce que vous étiez d'accord
avec la décision d'interdire cette tenue
j'ai pas eu l'impression que vous avez
regardé la en fait j'ai l'impression que
quelque soit la photo qui va vous
montrer donc pour vous c'est pas
important vous serez d'accord avec la
décision début d'après-midi la photo il
y a un minimum de préparation de cette
émission quand même un minimum monsieur
oui c'est pour ça que j'ai dit un
minimum franchement tous les deux on
regarde
vous me faites un mauvais procès
pour vous donc pour vous c'est
association c'est associé à une tenue
islamique je vous dis simplement que la
décision du chef d'établissement de
s'impose à une collégienne de 14 ans
c'est comme ça que ça marche dans la vie
votre fille votre fille toute fille peut
faire ce qu'elle veut en dehors de
l'école là il y a une décision il y a un
lien avec la religion c'est la question
qui était posée tu vois un lien là
il faut arrêter je précise que ma fille
elle a jamais été voilée donc donc elle
a jamais été voilée donc elle a jamais
eu de soucis à l'école par rapport à ça
donc moi je aujourd'hui je parle par
rapport à ce qui est arrivé que je
trouve très grave je trouve très grave
il a mis est-ce qu'elle allait en abaya
à l'école avant jamais de la vie elle a
jamais eu de souci par rapport à ça en
fait
je vais vous dire un truc tout simple ma
fille elle a reçu cette tenue comme
cadeau il y a au cours de l'été donc
elle a reçu deux tenues comme ça elle
était elle était contente elle était
affolée elle nous a montré donc
et donc
c'est c'est une mode c'est une nouvelle
mode il lui a dit quoi le proviseur ben
le proviseur il lui a dit que sa tenue
elle était assimilée et à une habaya une
donc et monsieur je vais préciser ma
pensée à partir du moment où il va y
avoir des centaines de cas comme ça
ambigus je peux moi
quelle est la tranchée c'est pas moi qui
vais la tranchée c'est le chef
d'établissement et le chef
d'établissement lui demande d'enlever je
veux dire d'enlever le haut pour pouvoir
rentrer à l'heure qu'elle avait un
débardeur en dessous je veux dire de
quel de quel droit de quel droit le chef
de l'État marche sur la tête voilà il
marche d'enlever et il m'a appelé c'est
à dire on m'a appelé il a laissé un
message à ma femme c'est
urgent il faut que vous appelez tout de
suite j'ai un problème j'ai votre fille
en ma présence il y a un problème
concernant votre mais ça a pris des
proportions énormes ça c'est autre moi
j'ai reçu un appel j'étais au boulot je
reçois un appel du proviseur donc il se
présente je suis le proviseur bah
heureusement que heureusement que c'est
pas ma femme qui l'a reçu ce ce coup de
téléphone donc je suis assez calme mais
je me suis inquiété je me suis dit je
suis arrivé un truc
c'est pas autre chose c'est le délire
concret et là il m'annonce que ma fille
en sa présence c'est que il me parle
d'abaya de mais je lui dis même mais ma
fille elle a jamais eu de Bayard le juge
il me parle d'abord pour ça mais je
comprenais pas il me dit il m'explique
qu'il lui a demandé de l'enlever elle a
pas voulu donc en fait j'ai rien compris
j'ai rien compris pour moi une abaya
c'est une c'est une tenue complète et
comment aussi on l'enlève qu'est-ce
qu'on a en dessous j'ai rien compris en
fait vous êtes d'accord avec Éric
Naulleau oui moi je suis d'accord avec
le la décision du chef d'établissement
parce que j'ai constaté qu'il y avait eu
plusieurs incidents qui ont été signalés
en France et moi je vois tout ça comme
une forme de défi lancé à la décision
d'un ministre alors ce n'est peut-être
pas la motivation de votre fille
monsieur je vais aller jusqu'au bout
puisque vous dites qu'elle a jamais
porté la Baya mais on a reçu lundi un
responsable islamique important et qui
lui-même a dit qu'il allait réagir et
que sa fille porterait le kimono dans
les jours qui suivent il y a eu d'autres
cas qui ont pas les signalé non mais
peut-être que la modification
si vous voulez tout le monde est-ce que
je peux préciser ma pensée pour éviter
les amalgames je m'interrog sur la
tactique qui est utilisée pourquoi à
partir du moment où il y a une
interdiction on dit non mais on va
porter des des vêtements amples on va
porter un kimono
on a bien vu par le passé qu'à chaque
fois qu'il y a des interdictions
derrière il y a une motivation de créer
le désordre de créer un précédent de
faire en sorte qu'ensuite on tombe sur
un juge qui soit finalement d'accord
avec et voilà et on va encore tomber
dans des appréciations un peu entre deux
non il y a une règle il y a une règle
arrêtons avec cette histoire le kimono
ça va être un bordel monstre ils vont
créer quoi par exemple
la seule chose avec laquelle je suis
d'accord avec Eric c'est sa première
partie c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'éducation il y a des choses beaucoup
beaucoup plus graves et à chaque fois on
passe tous les sujets très graves sous
silence pour des petites broutilles et
on en fait tout un truc ici ce n'est
absolument pas religieux c'est une tenue
bon bah c'est une tenue qui se trouve
dans le commerce c'est très joli alors
dans le temps moi je te commande
la liberté de poser sa robe sans qu'il y
ait des théories donc des Théo justement
pour rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit
j'ai été une fois renvoyé parce que
j'avais des bretelles trop fines et une
autre fois parce qu'on voyait un peu le
parce qu'on voyait un peu le ventre donc
chez nous c'était
chez nous c'était les bretelles larges
ou bien sûr ou alors on voyait pas le
ventre donc que le proviseur est demandé
carrément à votre fille d'enlever et
donc du coup on voit ses épaules
à la rigueur si on voit trop de peau
effectivement je comprends que ça puisse
déranger les garçons parce que moi c'est
ce qu'on m'avait dit mais si une jeune
fille est trop couverte d'une manière je
vois pas pourquoi ça dérangerait pour
lui elle est trop couverte mais le
problème il m'expliquait que le problème
c'est qu'elle était trop couverte quand
elle est la Bible était trop ample à un
moment je sais
il faut qu'on les laisse tranquille
c'est pauvre fille en fait quelle est la
motivation attendez on va se retrouver
dans un instant c'est quoi l'intérêt on
va se retrouver dans un instant quelle
est cette
c'est bon on va se retrouver dans un
instant les chéris on va finir là-dessus
et puis on va avoir donc Jacques Fri bon
donc vice-président de l'Association
pour la Promotion naturisme en liberté
qui sera avec nous
c'est pas pareil c'est de la transition
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]